design such an interesting thing with
apple and i think more than any other
company they are their work is
associated with design as we start to
look at this Apple watch is it function
first is it designed first I think it's
interesting about Apple is that we often
look at them as a technology company but
in fact they're usually a follow on the
technology front and they come in at the
moment where we're moving not from the
in the early adopter space but into the
sort of early majority excuse me early
majority and then they need to capture
also the late majority so in this case I
think they've seen a number of other
people entering the SmartWatch market
also in wearables they want to get close
to the body they want to own some of the
real estate on our bodies and as the
moment they see to get into that I
almost feel like they seated this about
by leaking news or great Bloomberg
reporters helped in that but by letting
the world know they were looking at a
watch for almost two years you had
competitors like just spitting stuff out
some of it really ill conceived but you
had Samsung you got motorola you of
course I've had the startups like Fitbit
and jawbone with her up it almost seems
like they want other people out there to
take the arrows and to experiment with
new things so they can figure out what
the world should be I think that they've
learned that being first isn't
necessarily it's important being best or
better than most is so yes they can they
can learn from the mistakes of others
and I think we've seen this being
telegraphed in a number of ways we've
even seen the evolution of the design
language I think from the apple laptops
shifting from a really hard edge to a
bit more of a softer end in the air or
do you mean already mean the world is
just we went we went from that that
specifically a perfect radius corner to
a bit of a softer more elliptical radius
and then you saw that move on to the
iPad and then you saw that move from
there into the iphone which got even
softer and as we get closer closer to
the body that's the sort of form that
we're going to want to have what's not
going to snag I'd close it's also going
to be a bit more comfortable i would
keep talk with us and i want to talk
about the bands in particular cuz i
think that's gonna be a focus late but i
always want to keep people updated with
the headlines and they're not really
talking about the the watch quite yet
Tim Cook still on stage of the event
he's talking about Apple pay at more
than 2,500 banks he's talking about
a car play which you know fits into what
we are talking about right here about
sort of simplicity and design and what
that means Apple apples now Tim Cook
saying more than 40 models of cars will
be shipping by the end of the year with
their apple carplay installed we know
that that takes a little while for the
car makers to catch up to that but Apple
clearly leading trying to lead the way
in a sort of design experience inside
the car same thing happening there
there's a ton of work going on the
connected car space and so there i'd say
they're also following in but ideally
with a bit more of a polished product so
i want to talking about what fashion is
and let's let's just get really high
minded here we might as well i mean what
is fashion mean apples device I would
think or Apple evel's approach to
devices has been this is a cut you know
this is a customizable device that you
can make of it what you will and you can
use it for what you will and you can use
the apps you choose to use and you can
put a picture your family on the front
or you can put a cool moving design that
we will supply to you but it's yours to
customize everyone gets the same thing
yeah the watch appears to be different
than that the watch appears to be here's
a basic version here's the fancy gold
edition is that a change in to be
something that is fashion that fashion
plays on two different levels ran on one
level we think of it as our peacock
feathers this is a way that we express
the outside world who we are and what we
stand for and so there's this element of
individuality and individual expression
the same time there's an element of
belonging of a group affinity I am a
punk therefore I dress like a punk I'm
affluent therefore I dress as if I'm a
flute and we send these signals I'm a
tech entrepreneur I'm in my hoodie so
here you have a similar sort of
circumstances working where Apple is
allowing you to signal a bit perhaps
with the gold watch or not and to morph
that look a bit to fit in with your own
look I'm about sport as opposed to gold
but at the same time you remember you're
joining this this group so it's no
longer really possible to say think
definitely not completely unique but
you're part of your identifying with a
group and and give us your 600 bucks and
we'll let you I think I think that's a
challenge because you are really
identifying
strongly with a group in a wearable
that's that seeing all the time as
opposed to one that's in your pocket